翻訳: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
校正: Hiroko Kawano
やぁ もうこの期待に満ちた眼差し
一体この丸太を持ってきて
何をやるのかって感じですけど
みなさんの 期待通り
ヘルメット置き場です
（笑）
さて みなさん
人は誰でも 生まれたときから
実はコミュニティの中にいます
まず家族というコミュニティ
皆さんはそこの一員としてまず生まれます
そしてそれは年を追うごとに
増えたり 変わっていったりします
友人や学校、会社、地域
そういったものですね
そして ほとんどの人は
そのコミュニティの中で
安心感や信頼できる関係を築きます
そこには
「顔が見える」そんな関係があるからです
例えば「おぉおい あれ取ってくれ」
「はいはい あれね」
そんなコミュニティの中でしか
通用しないような会話が成り立ったり
「あれって変だよね？」
「うん あれおかしいよね？」
そんな共通の問題意識をもてる
仲間であったり
そのほか コミュニティは
今日お集まりの皆さんのように
共通の目的を持った仲間のいる場所として
皆さんも 自分もその中にいると思います
それでも時に 閉ざされたコミュニティ
というものも存在します
そこでは 個人の考えよりも
受け継がれてきた考え
というものが尊重されて
それが「当たり前」という風潮が
浸透している場合があります
そこでは
それは その中でずっと生まれ育った人や
長い間その中に身を置いている人にとっては
当然「当たり前」
という考えなんですけれども
外からやってきた人にとっては
違和感を覚えることがあります
僕が—12年前です—
「日本の山を守りたい！」
そう思ってやってきた 天竜の森
そこには数百年受け継がれてきた
日本三大人工美林の一つと言われている
天竜の森と
そしてそこで営まれてきた
林業がありました
そこで僕は
きこりとして働き始めたんです
街からやってきた自分にとって
見るもの全てが新鮮でした
見渡す限り緑
満員電車も交通渋滞も無い
汗をかいて仕事をして
透き通った川の水で顔を洗う
緑の中で弁当を食べて
寝転ぶとこう 頭の上に
陽に透けた楓の葉がサラサラっと
揺れてるんですね
たまに地域のお年寄りから
「よくまぁ こんな何もないところに 」
そう言われたりもしましたけれども
一度もそう思ったことがありません
僕はこう思ってます
「ここには 都会にはないものが
全部ある」って
この仕事を選んで本当に良かった
林業は素晴らしい仕事だ
その思いは12年がたった今も
変わることはありません
しかし同時に 林業は閉ざされた
コミュニティでもありました
仕事に行けば会話をするのは２〜３人
というのが当たり前の世界なんです
それどころか
今日は誰にも会うことはなくて
会話をできたのはカモシカだけだった
そんな日もあったりします
森は仕事として関わる一部の人間にしか
開かれていない場所だったんです
そしてその中で
林業は色々な問題を抱えていました
就労人口の減少 高齢化
そして木材の価格の低迷
運び出してもコストの合わない木が
山の中に伐られては捨てられているんです
それでも伐らなくては
森は荒れて山が崩れてしまう
つまり 守るためには伐らなければいけない
という現実があったんです
守るために木の命を捨てなければいけない
自分にはそれをどうしても
当たり前の考えにすることはできませんでした
そこで仲間に伝えてみたんです
すると
こんな答えが返ってきました
「仕事だから仕方ねぇら？」です
現状を「仕方がない」という一言で
受け入れてしまうのは非常に簡単なことです
そして「仕方ない」と言ってしまえば
それ以上考えることもなくて済みます
それでもそれをどうしても自分は「当たり前」
として受け入れることはできなかったんですね
そこで考えました
この捨てられていく木があるという現実は
それを当たり前だと思っている
一部の人間しか知らない
もしかしたらこれを
大勢の街の方たちに伝えることができたら
何かが変わるかもしれない
そして 僕は決意しました
山を降りて 街へ行こう
街へ行って
森の中で自分たちきこりが
何をしているのか
街の人たちに伝えよう
森の課題も現状も
そしてもちろん 素晴らしいところも
街の人たちに伝えられる
「顔の見えるにきこり」になろう
小さな子どもたちとの木工体験に始まり
小中高生への出前講座
最初は子どもたちを目の前にして
うまく喋ることができなかったんですが
伝えては考えて 伝えては考えて
それを繰り返してくるうちに 今では
この程度には喋れるようになりました
そして丸太を担いで
チェーンソーを持って
街中でチェーンソーの実演をしたりしました
普段なら きこりがきこりとして
出かけて行かない場所へ行っては
街の人たちに 森のことを伝えました
それが１年 ２年
そして８年
気がつけば数千人の街の人たちに
森の話をしていたことになります
そして反対に 街の人たちを
今まで ほとんど街の人たちが
足を踏み入れたことがない
きこりたちのフィールドである
森に案内したんです
そこでも自分は一生懸命に
森の課題を伝えました
「木材の価格が低迷していて
それによって捨てられていく木があって」
その時 課題をかかえていた
自分が見ていたものは
スギやヒノキという いわば家の材料として
価値のあるものだけでした
ところが街の人たちは
同じ森の中で違うものを見てたんです
「あぁぁあ このコケかわいい！」
（笑）
「この葉っぱもらってもいいですか？」
街の人たちが求めるものって
一体なんだろう？
そこで ちょっと気付かされたんです
もしかしたら山の中には
スギやヒノキ以外にも
街の人たちが
求めるものがあるんじゃないのか？
作業の時に邪魔になるんで
刈って捨てられてしまう小さな木があるんです
街の人たち山に案内すると
その枝を折って香りを嗅いでもらうんです
すると ほとんどの人が「いい香り」
そう言って驚いてくれます
山の人にとっては
必要のないもの
街の人にとっては
良い香りのする驚くべきもの
例えば それを何かに活かせないか
試行錯誤の末 その木を
お茶にすることができました
今 そのお茶は浜松の街中のカフェで
飲むことができます
森の木のお茶
それは単なる商品開発ではなくて
お茶という
街の人たちが入りやすい入り口から
ちょっとだけ
森に入ってもらうためのものです
そしていつか実際に森へ足を運んでもらう
そして 森を身近なものとして
感じてもらうことが
これから街の人たちが森のことを考える上で
大切な一歩じゃないかと思ってるんです
街の人たちが求めるものは
スギやヒノキだけじゃない
ほかの植物も 環境も そして 森そのものも
街の人たちは求めているんだ
たくさんの人を山に案内する中で
そんなことに気がつきました
そして 自分が山を降りるきっかけになった
捨てられていく木
それもまた 街の人たちと出会えたことで
今一筋の光を見い出しています
自分が４年間関わっている
『フジモックフェス』というイベント
そのイベントの参加者の中から
木と向き合いすぎて 仕事を辞めて
自分で工場を借りて
木の加工をするという人が現れました
その人は 笑いながらこう言います
「木に人生狂わされた！」って　（笑）
でもね 気持ちは分かる気がするんです
自分も縁もゆかりもないところから
森や木というものに惹かれてここに来ました
木というものは日本人の心のどこか 奥底の
部分に訴えかける強い力があるんじゃないかと
毎日木と向きあっていながら
僕はそう思っています
そして今 そんな捨てられていた木は
本当に少しずつではありますが
そんな方たちの元で
こうした森のスピーカーのように
新たな命を与えられています
「森の課題を街の人たちに伝えたい」
最初の自分の思いは一方通行でした
ところが たくさんの町の人たちと
関わる中で
今まで繋がりにくかった
山と街を繋げるための
「顔の見えるきこり」になっている
そんな自分に気がつきました
山と街が一緒になった
新しいコミュニティ
今まで不要だったものを
活かすための考えは
そのコミュニティの中から
生まれてきています
現在 浜松の森林率って
66%あるんです
そしてそのうちの76%が
人が一本一本 木を植える
ことによって造られた
「人工林」と言われる
自分たちのきこりのフィールドなんです
そしてその大部分が
戦後の拡大造林
という政策によって作られた
いわば 70年近く前のデザインの
森なんです
それから 時代は変わりました
今でもまだまだ 山の中には
捨てられていく木があります
そして 人々の求める森の姿も
変わってきていると思います
自分は これからの森は
100年後の人たちにも必要とされる
そんな森であるべきだと思っています
100年後の山の人にも
街の人たちにも必要とされる森
今 自分は山を借りて
そんな森づくりを始めました
それでも森は数年ではできません
その森ができるまで
自分が生きていられるか
それもわかりません
それでも 自分は林業の中から
大切な考え方を学びました
林業は 森というバトンを
世代を超えて引き継ぐリレーなんです
祖父が植えて 父が育てた木を
自分が伐る
だから 自分が作ろうとしている森も
そうやって
次の世代に受け継がれていけば
それでいいと思います
ただその中には街の人たちも
入ってほしいんです
なぜなら 僕が造ろうと思っている森は
今 この地域に生きる人
そして これから
この地域に生きていく人への
きこりからの森のプレゼントだと
思っているからです
僕は森が大好きです
そして そこで働いている
きこりたちが大好きです
一昔前ならばきこりたちは
山の中でひっそりと木を伐っている
それだけでよかったんです
でもこれからは
ちょっと違うんじゃないかと思います
山や森に対する責任を
街の人たちや山の人たちが果たすために
毎日木と向き合い
山の現状を誰よりも知っている
そんなきこりたちが誇りを持って
声を上げるべきだと思います
そして 外に出れば
こうして今まで出会うことがなかった
たくさんの人たちがいて
そして
たくさんの違う考え方があります
そんな人たちと 今までなかった新しい
コミュニティを作る
当たり前を 当たり前じゃなくすための
ヒントがきっとその中にはあるはずです
僕は山を降りました
そしてたくさんの街の人たちと
繋がりました
今まで不要だったものに
価値を見い出すことができました
100年後の森のビジョンが見えてきました
そして何より
こうして 街の中に
自分と同じように森のことを考えてくれる
仲間がたくさんできました
「顔の見えるきこり」
そうなったことで 今自分の元には
現場作業員としては考えられないような
こういった素敵なお話を
たくさんいただいています
たまに 色々やりすぎて
一体 自分が何者だったのか
わからなくなってくることがあります
それでも「あなたは何者ですか？」
そう聞かれたら 僕は誇りを持って
こう答えたいと思います
「はい 自分は 天竜の 山のきこりです」
（拍手）